j'accueille galina valkova
[Musique]
ça va pas être stressé mais écoutez
c'est pas facile pour moi alors j'ai 29
ans vous êtes bulgare vous est ce qu'on
appelle une fille de l'est et vous
témoigner sur le destin de ces femmes
qui ont été aux mains des réseaux de
prostitution dans un livre rare et sans
concession intitulé une poupée qui dit
non publié chez calmann lévy alors vous
n'essayez dans une petite ville à 100 km
au nord de sofia votre père est en
prison dix ans de prison
et quand vous allez le voir en prison
vous avez peur et honte de ces visites
est à l'école quand on vous parle de
votre père vous dit j'ai pas de père
mais vous savez bien que vous en avez un
et les autres enfants savent bien aussi
que vous en avez un c'est vrai que
j'avais eu une enfance très très
difficile je
je suis mal j'avais du mal à porter
l'absence de mon père et en effet quand
il est revenu en fait j'ai découvert
quelqu'un qui
que je n'y connaissais pas du tout
apparemment très précise très violente
tu n'aurais tu pas d'exercer des villans
sur sur moi sur ma soeur c'est notre
famille et ça ça m'a beaucoup bouleversé
et puis le fait je je me suis enfermé
moi-même difficile c'est un mauvais
souvenir pour moi son retour de prison
effectivement votre père est très
tyrannique aussi tyrannique que votre
mère était indifférente à votre à votre
égard d'ailleurs pour des pour des
peccadilles pour des broutilles
il vous bas et c'est vrai que dans la
société bulgare s'est pas répréhensible
on peut dire c'est à dire que finalement
c'est très patriarcales comme société
oui oui les femmes s'exerce presque pas
parce que c'est vrai que celle des
hommes qui commande donc les femmes et
maîtresses mise
ma mère je me souviens d'elle
jamais pris mon défense elle était très
différente
moi ça me touche ça ça m'a beaucoup
choqué vraiment il est obligé à la
maison d'effectuer des tâches
domestiques ce qui vous interdit de vous
lancer dans une carrière sportive ce qui
aurait sans doute était pour vous une
solution vous dites pour devenir
quelqu'un d'autre
cette affaire c'était impossible que
j'ai réalisé un de mes rêves parce que
d'ailleurs j'avais très peu et puis
neuville que m'a donné ce qu'ils on
pouvait m'offrir une marina permet pas
matin matin alors la chute du communisme
c'est le marasme économique la sécurité
publiques se dégradent l'argent devient
le roi
c'est l'ère de la corruption du
banditisme de la prostitution de la
drogue est ce qui vous arrive de
regretter le communisme pas du tout
honnêtement pas du tout d'ailleurs s'est
aujourd'hui quand j'ai pris des reculs
de tout ça je me pose des questions
comment on peut vivre de ces conditions
comme ça c'est terrible de ces on
n'avait pas des paroles de s'exprimer en
avait le droit de rien de dire c'était
vraiment ne on était traitée en façon
comme un pas comme des êtres humains
chez d autres vont dire ça mais c'était
vraiment très très difficile
un jour tu perds vous surprend avec un
garçon vous allez saison il a 24 ans et
votre père vous oblige à les vivre avec
lui qui vous chasse de de chez vous oui
tout à fait quand je raconterai cette
personne
dilemme voilà pour mon père c'était
c'est impossible que je contacte avec un
an dont 1 diversion que je rencontrais
se disant ils pouvaient pas supporter
fait que moi je pouvait embrasser ou
couché avec un homme
donc il est préféré que je parle de chez
moi parce qu'ils n'avaient certainement
pas la première expérience sexuelle avec
ce garçon est extrêmement difficile ils
vous viole carrément 1 et ensuite peu à
peu vous apprenez à aimer l'amour mais
enfin disons que c'est une première
expérience qui n'a pas été très très
positif alors voilà un jour vous
apprenez que dylan vous a trompé voulu
plantée dans le bras le stylo que vous
avez à la main vous retourner vivre chez
vos parents
mais vous leur voyez vous tomber
enceinte vous avorté vous le quittez
et là vous avez sentiment peut-être
aujourd'hui d'avoir laissé passer le
grand amour de votre vie non je pense
oui je le pense parce que
en fait aujourd'hui je me rendis compte
peut être que j'ai le vraiment demain
cette personne et c'est vrai que quand
j'étais enfant je prie de contacter ses
derniers moments avec lui
qui
et quand j'entends de se voir et surtout
ce qui me disait ça m'a beaucoup touché
c'est à dire qu'il doit toujours penser
à moi il m'a toujours aimé vie m'a même
demandé de permission b e s qui peut se
marier jeudi me tout au fait je devrais
offerte aux visites j'ai manqué ma
chance avec lui je considère ça comme ça
mais on verra bien la lumière est là on
est en 1994 et 18 ans vous êtes invités
par une ancienne camarade de lycée un
anniversaire dans une discothèque
vous vous amusez puis d'un seul coup
vous commencez à perdre un peu
connaissance quand je me suis retrouvée
de cette discothèque en fait après je
constatais cost est drogué et avec la
drogue américaine c'est quoi mais je
sais pas exactement mais c'est un trop
gros qui qu'il inverse de l'hiver dans
les boissons et on ne voit rien se voit
pas du tout c'est invisible
c'est invisible voilà vous vous
réveillez au sein du clan e-gov qui sont
des tziganes qui vivent grassement du
proxénétisme
vous retrouvez à 200 km de chez vous
dans un appartement assez luxueux
d'ailleurs le chef du clan staff show
igor vous présente doute prostituées qui
travaillent là aussi mais la
fraternisation est impossible non non
parce que déjà une golf quand je le
faisais il m'a faisaient tellement peur
et comme d'ailleurs avant j'en avais
tellement peur pour moi c'était c'était
la peur totale dès que je me suis
retrouvée de centrage
je croyais que pour moi c'est fini donc
vraiment un kit est possible d
imaginaires ce moment donc si grave mais
sur le trottoir au début vous avez du
mal à aborder des clients à monter avec
eux mais mais on vous dresse vous dites
on me dresser c'est vrai que votre père
avait un peu préparé le terrain la façon
dont ils vous traitez finalement vous
prédisposé à subir ça oui je considère
ça comme ça
vous étiez la proie idéale pour ces
procès alors vous pensé un moment à les
voir des policiers mais vous savez que
la corruption règne et vous vous dites
que finalement les policiers doivent
être de mèche avec les proxénètes sans
hésitation oui je pense que même à
l'heure actuelle en bulgarie des
corruptions irène chacun impose sa loi
comme il peut bien sûr le vétéran rossi
qui règne c'est pour moi c'est un
c'est un pays avec clin d'oeil marchi n
a rien qui va et je suis contente quand
la prostitution devient pour vous la
routine puis vous êtes rentable parce
que non seulement vous êtes belle en
plus vous êtes infatigable vous êtes dit
vous une véritable machine à sous pour
ces gens là mais vous n'en est pas moins
une esclave je considérais de l'edough
parce que j'étais les deux en fait
c'était l'ami l'ordre parce que je
donnais plus c'était plus désirable de
tout et puis tout ce qu'il me disait de
faire je le bienfait donc vraiment
j'étais un véritable machine de sauts
sans limite
cinq minutes à un moment vous essayez de
faire une fugue mais vous êtes te
rattraper roué de coups attaché trois
jours un radiateur sans eau et sans
nourriture
malgré tout vous devenez rapidement la
la favorite du chef savent chaud donc
vous êtes prostituées la journée et
femme du chef le soir ils sont très
paradoxale oui oui c'était terrible mais
en fait je comprenais pas sans réaction
pourquoi moi pourquoi ma choisi que au
fur et à mesure quand j'étais tout près
de lui j'ai pas que
il avait été close pour moi et tout
particulier et je sais pas aujourd'hui
comment m'expliquer ce traitement
il alterne avec vous les coûts et les
cadeaux ce qui fait qu'au bout d'un
moment vous vous retrouver complètement
démoli psychologiquement alors vous
prostituées vous faites avortées vous
entendez même pas une semaine ou quinze
jours tiens vous recommencer à
travailler pratiquement le jour même de
l'avortement c'est absolument
épouvantable vous attrapez la syphilis à
un moment et est finalement c'est après
une tentative pour vous retrouver après
vous ayez été vendue il ya une fusillade
que le chef du clan et gris en bulgarie
et qui part en france
il vous emmène avec lui à toulouse
vous vous retrouvez sur le trottoir à
toulouse là vous connaissez rien vous
connaissez trois phrases de français au
sujet du prix des prestations c'est tout
quoi ah oui et en plus elle est humain
prix que c'était bien évident que déjà
il y avait d'autres filles qui a mené
ici en france direction directement
toulouse
donc il m'a expliqué il m'a donné à
l'extraction tout de suite comment faire
ou est-ce que je vais travailler plus
tôt lui est arrêté par les policiers il
parvient à s'échapper ils rentrent donc
en bulgarie à son retour il vous prête
un patron de bar macédonien donc en
france
vous devenez bonne serveuse put du bar
vous dormez cinq heures par nuit et là
en 1998 quand vous êtes arrêté avec igor
vous décidé de coopérer avec les
policiers parce que j'ai eu tellement
marre de ces quatre années passées et
par lieu de ma vie avec plein de
souffrance et je trouve ça je ne sais
pas un moment donné je je croyais que
influencer la justice et à le voit donc
j'espérais vraiment de retrouver ma
liberté
c'est très courageux est ce que vous
avez fait oui je pense aussi mais ça m'a
fait pas vraiment compliment c'est parce
que
je trouve au casque ou rejouer mais moi
je ne suis je vais pas me réjouir de ça
parce que je sais comment j'ai risqué ma
vie
à quel prix bien sûr parce que la league
of you que tu as eu ma chérie je te
retrouverai alors en procès vous
témoigner il est condamné à 13 ans de
prison
il vous dit tu verras je n'oublierai pas
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
compte tenu des remises de peine de la
liberté conditionnelle ils risquent de
sortir avant et de vous retrouver
oui je pense je pense qu'on revient sur
sa aussi parce que en bulgarie avec
leurs jambes c'est le pouvoir
on peut faire tout et lui en a
suffisamment donc il peut se payer le
liberté est bien là et je sais pas où il
faut que je me trouve c'est à ce moment
là parce que vraiment
en plus je me sens semble protection ici
en france il ya un truc que je revois
basque en amérique par exemple quand des
gens coopèrent avec la police pour
dénoncer des mafieux par exemple ils
sont protégés par l'état américain ici
là la france ne vous protège pas vous
avez vous avez aidé à démanteler un
réseau de prostitution et la france ne
vous protège pas mais non parce que je
pense pas que cette loi existe en france
d'ailleurs si ça existe mois et la
personne qui m'a n'en parlait de ça donc
vraiment je suis pas au courant de ça en
tout cas moi je suis sans protection
nous orly ouais c'est clair c'est que
vous dites la peur gangrène ma vie je ne
rentrent jamais chez moi sans regarder
qui me suit et ça pour moi c'est pénible
c'est invivable parce que à vivre
toujours dans la peur à se méfier de
tout le monde un moment donné ça
devienne une obsession
et moi j'ai plus envie de sang ce plan
vise envie de voir en vie normale
vivre comme tout le monde normalement à
m'amuser aller quelque part semble 100
des titres et c'est terrible je sais pas
ce qui se passe mais si quelqu'un
regarde cette émission elle peut faire
quelque chose pour elle ça serait quand
même la moindre des choses parce que
quand même aider à démanteler un réseau
de prostitution et elle se retrouve
aujourd'hui sans protection c'est quand
même incroyable non quel courage
galina malte au vent
ces quatre années la pêche et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu